[Music]
the important link between play and
learning has been around a lot longer
than video games play is not frivolous
in fact central to our learning game
design philosophy is the idea that we
develop models of the world and prepare
for and reinforce deeper understanding
through experiences of play
Mountain Goats play by jumping from
ledge to ledge and cliff to cliff they
do that not just when they're looking
for food or when they're escaping prey
but really in their in their downtime in
their spare time and they play at it in
spite of the fact that occasionally they
fall and occasionally they die doing it
now if you know anything about evolution
you'd say that a behavior that causes
the death of an organism tends to die
out but this one persists this behavior
so clearly there are advantages that far
outweigh the costs
most of us are familiar with kittens or
puppies playing and if you've ever
observed them at all you probably notice
that they play at hunting and it would
be easy to conclude between the mountain
goats and the kittens that what they're
all they're doing is learning by rote
sort of the moves you have to do to hunt
but in reality a cat who's deprived of
the ability to play will still hunt fine
but what it won't know how to do is how
to interact with other cats and how to
make decisions in new situations I like
to characterize it in terms of four
freedoms the first freedom to experiment
the blocks I was clearly no one said
this is what you do with blocks you
build these structures you see a lot of
play nowadays where that happens where
you get you buy the lego star wars tie
fighter and all you can build as a TIE
fighter as opposed to an open box of
late Lego where you can build anything
you want well anyway so I had the
freedom to experiment relate to that as
the freedom to fail when you build we do
play with stuff things don't always work
that's got to be part of the game
imagine a kid building a block tower
with a parent standing behind him saying
okay that's a nice Tower but whatever
you do don't let that tower fall down
think about how can how uncomfortable
that play would become if the child was
worried about failing or we can build
this we can build a sandcastle at the
beach but don't build it close enough to
the water because it might get washed
away I mean that's part of the fun right
failure is part of the game part of play
freedom to try on identities think about
your own play when your play when you
were little when you were young and you
played with dolls or stuffed animals and
you were acting out all the different
people you knew and the kind of roles do
you you encounter in life parents
children authority figures bullies you
played out all those different roles
when you were kid you're trying them all
on you're trying to see what it feels
like to be all the different things you
might be in life that's a critical part
of play find the freedom of effort it's
really important when you're playing
that no one tells you you got to play
hard right now in fact when you're
playing sometimes you play hard
sometimes you put him in a relaxed way
that's entirely up to the player the
minute someone says okay get going get
to work it stops being play so how do we
channel play into activities while still
keeping them open-ended and that's where
games come in because games are so kind
of organized play if you think about a
game of golf it would be much easier if
you just
whit's a golf course and you took the
ball and you walk the other end of the
golf course and you just drop the ball
in the hole right that would that's your
job right get the ball in the hole so I
didn't just drop it in it doesn't sound
like a whole lot of fun though does it
who plays golf along with some people in
this room presidents play golf
CEOs play golf important people play
golf what they do they spend time
hitting this little ball with a long
stick in the most difficult way possible
just to get it in the hole when you know
the president could hire the Secret
Service to go and drop the ball in the
hole but that's not the way it works so
why do people do that it is part of our
nature to play and it is part of our
nature to rise to challenges when
presented to us if those challenges are
interesting they don't have to be
meaningful in the way that religion or
philosophy is meaningful but they but
they're challenging and they're
interesting and so we we rise to those
challenges and that means that we as
designers if we put interesting
challenges in front of people I'd argue
we can get them to think about things
and do things that they might not
otherwise have an opportunity to think
about or do how often are you allowed to
fail in school how often are you ever
encouraged
to to make you see your failures in
school or even learn from your failures
and certainly and experimenting in
school usually how many science labs
actually ask you to really experiment I
mean most science labs you sit there and
you do the list in the order that is and
and if you don't get the result that you
think the teacher wanted maybe you faked
it
maybe because the idea that you could
learn from the failed experiment you
know and forget about identities right
you know even though you're not you're
not loud to come in one day and say I
feel like being this person and you're
certainly not allowed to they're
certainly no allowance for the fact that
one day you feel like working hard in
the next day you don't I don't want you
to think about how can i replicate
school in a game not that there aren't
lots of really good things in school but
I think school the way you experience it
on a day to day basis is not what you
want to replicate in a game